[light rock music]
- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of neurobiology
and ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine.
Today my guest is Dr. Charles Zuker.
Dr. Zuker is a professor of biochemistry
and molecular biophysics
and of neuroscience
at Columbia University School of Medicine.
Dr. Zuker is one of the world's
leading experts in perception.
That is how the nervous system
converts physical stimuli
in the world into events within
the nervous system that we come
to understand as our sense of smell,
our sense of taste,
our sense of vision, our sense of touch,
and our sense of hearing.
Dr. Zuker's lab
is responsible for a tremendous amount
of pioneering and groundbreaking work
in the area of perception,
for a long time his
laboratory worked on vision,
defining the very receptors
that allow for the conversion
of light into signals that the rest
of the eye and the brain can understand.
In recent years,
his laboratory is focused mainly
on the perception of taste.
And indeed his laboratory is
responsible for discovering
many of the taste receptors leading
to our perception of
things like sweetness,
sourness, bitterness,
saltiness, and umami.
That is savoriness in food.
Dr. Zuker's laboratory is also responsible
for doing groundbreaking
work on the sense of thirst.
That is how the nervous
system determines whether
or not we should ingest more fluid
or reject fluids that are offered to us.
A key feature of the work
from Dr. Zuker's laboratory
is that it bridges the brain and body.
As you'll soon learn
from today's discussion.
His laboratory has discovered
a unique set of sugar sensing
neurons that exist not
just within the brain,
but a separate set of neurons.
That sense sweetness and
sugar within the body.
And that much of the
communication between the brain
and body leading to our seeking of sugar
is below our conscious detection.
Dr. Zuker has received a large
number of prestigious awards
and appointments as a consequence
of his discoveries in neuroscience.
He is a member of the
National Academy of Sciences,
the National Academy of Medicine,
and the American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
He is also an investigator
with the Howard Hughes Medical Institute.
For those of you that are not familiar
with the so-called HHMI,
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute,
Howard Hughes Medical Institute
investigators are selected
on an extremely competitive basis.
And indeed they have to
come back every five years
and prove themselves worthy
of being reappointed as
Howard Hughes investigators,
Dr. Zuker has been a Howard
Hughes investigator since 1989.
What all that means for you as a viewer
and or listener of today's podcast,
is that you are about to
learn about the nervous system
and its ability to create
perceptions in particular,
the perception of taste and sugar sensing
from the world's expert
on perception and taste.
I'm certain that by the
end of today's podcast,
you're not just going to
come away with a deeper
understanding of our perceptions
and our perception of taste in particular.
But indeed you will come
away with an understanding
of how we create internal representations
of the entire world
around us and in doing so,
how we come to understand
our life experience.
I'm pleased to announce that
the Huberman Lab Podcast
is now partnered with
Momentous Supplements.
We often talk about supplements
on the Huberman Lab Podcast
and while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them.
For things like enhancing
the quality and speed
with which you get into sleep
or for enhancing focus
or for hormone support.
The reason we partnered
with Momentous Supplements
is several fold.
First of all, their supplements are
of the absolute highest quality.
Second of all, they ship internationally,
which is important because many
of our podcast listeners
reside outside the US.
Third, many of the supplements
that Momentous makes and most all
of the supplements that we partnered
with them directly on are
single ingredient formulations.
This is important for a number of reasons.
First of all, if you're going to create
a supplement protocol that's
customized for your needs,
you want to be able to figure
out which supplement ingredients
are most essential and only
use those and supplements
that combine lots of ingredients simply
won't allow you to do that.
So in trying to put together
a supplement protocol for yourself,
that's the most biologically effective
and cost effective single
ingredient formulations
are going to be the most useful.
If you'd like to see the
supplements that we partner
with Momentous on, you can go
to livemomentous.com/huberman,
and there you'll see
many of the supplements
that we've talked repeatedly about
on the Huberman Lab Podcast episodes.
I should mention that the
catalog of supplements
that are available at
livemomentous.com/Huberman
is constantly being expanded.
So you can check back there,
livemomentous.com/huberman to see
what's currently available.
And from time to time,
you'll notice new supplements
being added to the inventory.
Before we begin, I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford.
It is however, part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science related tools
to the general public in
keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics
and for frequent
listeners of this podcast,
you may remember that I'm
not a big fan of the word
nootropics because the word nootropics
means smart drugs or smart compound.
And the reason I don't like
that phrase is that the brain
has many different circuits
that it uses in order
to perform things like focus
or task switching or creativity.
So the idea that there's a
single thing that we would call
a smart drug is simply not
in concert with the biology.
Well, Thesis understands this,
and as a consequence has
developed custom nootropic
formulations that are
tailored to your unique needs.
So for instance,
Thesis will allow you to
try different blends over
the course of a month and determine
which blends of specific
ingredients work best
for you to focus or for
you to gain motivation
and energy for workouts or
for cognitive work of some sort.
I've been using Thesis custom nootropics
for well over six months now.
And they completely transform
the way that I do cognitive
work and indeed the way
that I do physical fitness,
if you want to try your
own personalized nootropic starter kit,
you can go online to
takethesis.com/huberman.
There you'll just do a brief
three minute quiz and Thesis will
send you four different formulas
to try in your first month.
That's takethesis.com/huberman
and use the code Huberman at checkout
to get 10% off your first box.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are the absolute highest quality.
The company was founded by two
all American swimmers from Stanford
and everything about ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed with performance
in mind and with the biology
of the visual system in mind,
I spent my lifetime working
on the visual system,
and I can tell you that your
visual system has to contend
with a number of very
important challenges in order
to be able to see the
world around you clearly,
things like adjusting for
background illumination so that
when you go from a sunny
area to a shady area,
you can see what's in front
of you still with crystal clarity.
ROKA takes all of that into account
when designing their
eyeglasses and sunglasses,
their eyeglasses and sunglasses
also have some unique
qualities for instance,
because they were initially designed
for performance with things
like running and cycling.
If you get sweaty, they
won't fall off your face.
Also they're extremely lightweight.
In fact, most of the time,
I don't even remember
that I'm wearing them.
I wear ROKA eyeglasses at night.
So I wear readers and
I wear sunglasses often
during the day, if it's very
bright or if I'm driving,
if you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses,
you can go to ROKA
that's roka.com and enter
the code Huberman to save
20% off your first order.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Helix Sleep.
Helix Sleep makes mattresses and pillows
that are uniquely tailored
to your sleep needs.
I've talked repeatedly
about the fact that sleep
is the foundation of mental health,
physical health, and performance.
So getting adequate deep
sleep is absolutely essential.
Now, one of the key things to getting
a great night's sleep is to make sure
that the surface that you're sleeping on
is the right one for you.
Helix understands this,
and they've created a sleep quiz.
That is you go to their
website and you fill out
a brief quiz that asks questions
like you sleep on your side,
your back, your stomach.
Do you tend to run hotter
cold during the night?
Maybe you don't know the answers.
In which case you simply
say you don't know,
by taking that quiz,
they will match you to a mattress
that is ideal for your sleep needs.
I took that quiz and I
matched to the so-called Dusk,
D-U-S-K mattress.
And I've been sleeping on that
mattress for some time now,
and it's the best sleep
that I've ever had.
So if you're interested in
upgrading your mattress to one,
that's uniquely tailored
to your sleep needs,
you can go to helixsleep.com/huberman,
take their two minute sleep quiz,
and they'll match you to
a customized mattress.
And you'll get up to $200
off any mattress order
and two free pillows.
They have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try out
that mattress for a
hundred nights, risk free.
They'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it,
but I do believe
that you will love it because you'll be
sleeping far better than you have before.
Again, if you're interested,
you can go to helixsleep.com/huberman
to get up to $200 off
and two free pillows.
And now for my discussion
with Dr. Charles Zuker,
Charles, thank you so
much for joining me today.
- My pleasure.
- I want to ask you
about many things related
to taste and gustatory perception,
but maybe to start off
and because you've worked
on a number of different
topics in neuroscience,
not just taste,
how do you think about perception,
or rather, I should say,
how should the world and
people think about perception,
how it's different from
sensation and what leads
to our experience of
life in terms of vision,
hearing, taste, et cetera?
- So the brain is an extra ordinary organ
that weights maybe 2% of your body mass.
Yet it consumes anywhere between 25
to 30% of all of your energy and oxygen.
And it gets transformed into a mind
and this mind changes the human condition.
It make, it changes, it
transforms fear into courage,
conformity into creativity,
sadness into happiness.
How the hell does that happen?
Now, the challenge that the brain faces
is that the world is made of real things.
You know, this here is a glass,
and this is a cord and
this is a microphone,
but the brain is only made of neurons
that only understand electrical signals.
So how do you transform
that reality into nothing
that electrical signals that now need
to represent the world?
And that process
is what we can operationally
define as perception,
in the senses, let's say olfactory,
other taste, vision we
can very straightforwardly
separate detection from perception,
detection is what happens when
you take a sugar molecule,
you put it in your tongue and
then a set of specific cells
now sense that sugar
molecule that's detection,
you haven't perceived anything yet.
That is just your cells in your tongue,
interacting with this chemical.
But now that cell gets
activated and sends a signal
to the brain and now detection
gets transformed into perception.
And he's trying to
understand how that happens.
That's been the maniacal drive,
of my entire career in neuroscience.
How does the brain ultimately
transform detection
into perception so that it can
guide actions and behaviors?
Does that make sense?
- Absolutely.
And is a very clear and
beautiful description,
a sort of high level
question related to that.
And then I think we can get
into some of the intermediate steps.
I think many people would
like to know whether
or not my perception of the color
of your shirt is the
same as your perception
of the color of your shirt.
- Excellent question.
Am I okay to interrupt you
as I'm guessing what you're going?
- Interruption is welcome on this podcast.
The audience will always penalize me
for interrupting you,
and will never penalize
you for interrupting me.
- Good, I like the one way penalize.
Now, given what I told you before
that the brain is trying to represent
the world based in nothing
but the transformation of
these signals into electrical
languages that now neurons
had to encode and decode.
It follows that your brain
is different than my brain.
And therefore it follows that
the way that you are perceiving
the world must be different
than mine, even when receiving
the same sensory cues.
And I'll tell you about an experiment
is a simple experiment yet brilliant.
That demonstrates why
we perceive the world,
how we perceive the world different.
So in the world of vision, as you know,
well now we have three classes
of photo receptor neurons
that sense three basic
colors, red, blue, and green.
Blue, green, and red
if we go from short to long wavelength
and these three are
sufficient to accommodate
the full visible spectra,
I'm going to take three light projectors,
and I'm going to project
with one into a wide screen,
a red light, and the
other one green light,
I'm going to overlap the two beams.
And on the screen, there's be yellow.
This is the superposition
when you have two beams of red and green,
and then I'm going to
take a third projector
and I'm going to put a filter
that projects right
next to that mixed beam,
a spectral pure yellow.
And I'm going to ask you to
come to the red and green
projectors and play with intensity knobs
so that you can match that yellow
that you're projecting to the
spectrally pure next to it.
Is this making sense?
- Perfect sense.
- And I'm going to write down the numbers
in those two volume
intensity knobs and then I'm going to ask
the next person to do the same.
And then I'm going to
ask every person around
this area of Battery Park
in New York to do the same,
and guess what, we're going to end up
with thousands of different
number combinations.
- Amazing.
- So for all of us,
is yellow enough that we
can use a common language,
but for every one of us,
that yellow is going to be
ever so slightly differently.
And so I think that simple
psychological experiment
beautifully illustrates
how we truly perceive
the world differently.
- I love that example.
And yet, in that example,
we know the basic elements
from which color is created.
If we migrate into a
slightly different sense,
let me pick a hard one, like-
- Sound.
- Sound, olfaction.
- Very hard then to do an experiment
that will allow us to get that degree
of granularity and beautiful causality,
where we can show that A
produces and leads to B.
If I give you the smell of a rose,
you can describe it to me.
If I smell the same rose,
I can describe it also,
but I have no way whether
the two of us are experiencing the same,
but it's close enough that
we can both pretty much say
that it has the following enough features
or other determinants,
but no question that your
experience is different than mine.
- The fact that it's good
enough for us to both survive
that your perception of yellow
and my perception of yellow at least up
until now is good enough
for us both to survive.
- You got it.
- Raises a thought
about a statement made by a colleague
of ours, Marcus Meister at Caltech.
It's never been on this podcast,
but in a review that I read
by Marcus, at one point,
he said that the basic
function of perception
is to divide our behavioral responses
into the outcomes downstream
of three basic emotional responses.
Yum.
I like it.
Yuck.
I hate it.
Or meh, whatever.
What do you think about,
I'm not looking to establish a debate
between you and Marcus,
without Marcus here.
- I understand that.
- But what I like about
that is that it seems like
we know the brain is a very
economical organ in some sense,
despite its high metabolic
demands and this variation
in perception from one
individual to the next, at once,
seems like a problem because
we're all literally
seeing different things.
And yet we function,
we function well enough for
most of us to avoid death
and cliffs and eating poisons and so forth
and to enjoy some aspects
of life one hopes.
So is there a general statement
that we can about the brain,
not just as a organ to
generate perception,
not just as an organ to keep us alive,
but also an organ that is trying to batch
our behaviors into general
categories of outcome?
- I think so, but, and again,
I think the world of Marcus too,
and I think he's right
that broadly speaking,
you could categorize a
lot of behaviors falling
into those two categories
and that's 100% likely
to be the case for
animals in the wild where
the choices are not necessarily binary,
but they're very unique and distinct.
Do I want to eat this?
Do I want to kill that?
Do I want to go there?
Or do I want to go here?
We humans deviated from
that world long ago.
And learned to experience life
where we do things that
we should not be doing.
- Some of us more than others.
- Exactly.
You know, in my own world of taste,
the likelihood that an animal
in the wild will enjoy
eating something bitter
it's inconceivable, yet
we love tonic water.
We enjoy, we like living on the edge.
We love enjoying experiences
that makes us human.
And that goes beyond that
simple set of categories,
which is yummy, yukky, ah, who cares.
And so I think it's not a bad palette,
but I think it's overly reductionist
for certainly what we humans do.
- I agree.
And since we're here in New York,
I can say that the many options,
the extensive variety of food,
flora and fauna in New York explains
a lot of the more nuanced
behaviors that we observe.
Let's talk about taste because although
you've done extensive work
in the field of vision,
and it's a topic that
I love you could spend
all day on taste is fascinating.
First of all, I'd like to know
why you migrated from studying
vision to studying taste.
And perhaps in that description,
you could highlight to us
why we should think about
and how we should think
about this sense of taste.
- My goal has been to understand,
as I highlighted before how
the brain does its magic,
you know what part you
might wonder, ideally,
I like to help contribute
to understand all of it.
You know how do you encode
and decode emotions?
How do you encode and
decode memories and actions?
How do you make decisions?
How do you transform
detection into perception?
And the list goes on and on.
But one of the key things
in science, as you know,
is ensuring that you always
ask the right question
so that you have a
possibility of answering it.
Because if the question
cannot be tractable or reduced
to an experimental path
that helps you resolve it,
then we end up doing
some really fun science,
but not necessarily answering
the important problem
that we want to study.
Make sense?
- From a first person perspective, yes.
The hardest question,
the most important question
is what are you going
to try and answer.
- You got it.
And so for example
I will have to understand
the neural basis of empathy.
- [Andrew] There's a big market for that.
- 100%, but I wouldn't even know.
I mean, at the molecular
level, that's what we do.
How do the circuits in your
brain create that sense?
I have no clue how to do it.
I can come up with ways to think about it,
but I like to understand what
in your brain makes someone
a great philanthropist.
What is the neural basis of love?
I wouldn't even know where to begin.
So if I want to begin to study
these questions about brain function,
that can cover so many
aspects of the brain,
I need to choose a problem
that affords me that window.
But in a way that I can ask questions
that get me answers and among the senses
that have the capacity
of transforming detection into perception
of being stored as memories
or creating emotions,
of giving you different
actions and perceptions
as a function of the internal state.
You know, when you're hungry,
things taste very differently
that when you're sated,
how, why?
When you taste something,
you now remember this amazing meal
you had with your first
date, how does that happen?
So if I want to begin to
explore all of these things
that the brain does,
I felt I have to choose a
sensory system that affords
some degree of simplicity in the way
that the input output
relationships are put together.
And in a way that still can
be used to ask every one
of these problems that the brain
has to ultimately compute,
encode and decode.
And what's remarkable
about the taste system at the time
that I began working on this
is that nothing was known
about the molecular basis of taste.
You know, we knew that we could taste
what has been usually defined as
the five basic taste
qualities, sweet, sour,
bitter, salty, and umami,
umami is a Japanese word
that means yummy, delicious.
And that's nearly every animal species,
the taste of amino acids.
And in humans, it's mostly
associated with the taste of MSG,
monosodium glutamate, one
amino acid in particular.
- What are just by way of example,
some foods that are rich in
the umami evoking stimulation?
- Seaweed, tomatoes, cheese,
eh, and it's a great,
great flavor enhancer.
It enriches our sensory experience.
And so the beautiful thing of the system
is that the lines of
input are limited to five.
You know, sweet, sour,
bitter, salt and umami,
and each of them has a
predetermined meaning,
you are born liking sugar
and disliking bitter.
You have no choice.
These are hard wire systems,
but of course you can
learn to dislike sugar
and to like bitters, but in the while,
let's take humans out of the question,
these are a hundred percent predetermined.
You are born with that specific
valance value for each taste
of sweet, umami and low salt
are attractive taste qualities.
They evoke appetitive responses,
I want to consume them.
And bitter and sour are innately,
predetermined to be aversive.
- Could I interrupt you just briefly
and ask a question about that exact point
for something to be appetitive to and some
other taste to be aversive
and for those to be hardwired,
can we assume that the
sensation of very bitter
or of activation of bitter receptors
in the mouth activates a neural circuit
that causes closing of the mouth,
retraction of the tongue
and retraction of the body
and that the taste of something sweet
might actually induce more licking?
- 100%, you got it,
the activation of the
receptors in the tongue
that recognize sweet versus the ones
that recognize bitter activate
an entire behavioral program.
And that program that we
can refer as appetitiveness
or aversion it's composed of
many different subroutines,
in the case of bitter is very
easy to actually look at,
see them happening in animals.
Because the first thing
you do is you stop licking.
Then you put unhappy face,
then you squint your eyes
and then you start gagging.
And that entire thing
happens by the activation
of a bitter molecule
in a bitter sensing cell in your tongue.
- It's incredible.
- It's again,
the magic of the brain,
how it it's able to encode
and decode these extraordinary
actions and behaviors in
response of nothing but a simple,
very unique sensory stimuli.
Now, let me say that this
pallet of five basic tastes
accommodates all the dietary
needs of the organism.
Sweet to ensure that we get
the right amount of energy,
umami, to ensure that we get proteins
and that essential nutrient, salt,
the three appetitive ones to ensure
that we maintain our electrolyte balance,
bitter to prevent the ingestion
of toxic nauseous chemicals,
nearly all bitter tasting
things out in the wild are bad for you,
and sour, most likely to prevent ingestion
of spoil acid,
fermented foods.
And that's it.
That is the pallet that we deal with.
Now, of course,
there's a difference between
basic taste and flavor,
flavor is the whole experience.
Flavor is the combination of
multiple tastes coming together
together with smell, with
texture, with temperature,
with the look of it
that gives you what you
and I would call the
full sensory experience.
But, but we scientists need to reduce
the problem into its basic elements.
So we can begin to break it apart
before we put it back together.
So when we think about the sense of taste,
and we try to figure out how
these lines of information
go from your tongue to your brain
and how they signal and
how they could integrate it
and how they trigger all
these different behaviors.
We look at them as individual qualities,
so we give the animals sweet,
or we give them a bitter.
We give them sour,
we avoid mixes because the first stage of
discovery is to have that
clarity as to what you're trying
to extract so that you can
hopefully meaningfully make
a difference by being able to figure out
how easy that A goes to B to C and to D,
does this make sense?
- Yeah, almost like the primary colors
to create the full array
of the color spectrum.
- Exactly.
- Before I ask you about the first
and second and third stages of
taste and flavor perception,
is there any idea that
there may be more than five?
- There is, for example, what about fat?
- I love the taste.
- Oh, I love fat too.
And I love the texture of fat,
especially if it's slightly burnt,
like in South America, when
I visited Buenos Aries,
I found that at the end of a
meal, they would take a steak,
the trimming off the edge of
the steak, burn it slightly,
and then serve it back to me.
And I thought that's disgusting.
And then I tasted it and it's delightful.
- It is.
- There's nothing quite like it.
- This goes back to this notion
before that we like to live on the edge.
And we like to do things
that we should not be doing, Andrew,
but on the other hand,
look at those muscles.
- I don't suggest anyone eat pure fat.
The listeners of this
podcast will immediately,
I'm sure there'll be a YouTube video soon
that I like eating pure fat.
I'm not on a ketogenic diet, et cetera,
but fat is tasty as evidenced by
the obesity problem that
exists in this country.
- We'll talk about that.
You know, in a little bit about
the gut brain axis,
I think it'll be important to cover it
because it's the other
side of the taste system.
And so missing taste, one is fat,
although like you clearly
highlighted a lot of fat taste
in quotation marks is really
the feeling of fat rolling on your tongue.
And so there is a compelling argument
that a lot of what we call fat taste,
it's really mechanosensory,
it's somatosensory cells,
cells that are not responding to taste,
but they're responding
to mechanical stimulation
of fat molecules rolling on the tongue
that gives you that perception of fat.
- I love the idea that there
is a perception of fat,
regardless of whether or not
there's a dedicated receptor for fat,
mostly because it's evoking sensations
and imagery of the taste
of slightly burnt fat.
- For example.
And another one you could
argue is metallic taste.
You know, I know exactly
what it tastes like.
You know, if you ask me to explain it,
I will have a hard time,
what are the palettes of that color
that can allow me to define it?
It wouldn't be easy,
but I know precisely what it tastes like,
take take a penny, put it in your mouth
and you know what it tastes like.
- Or blood.
That's another very good example.
And is there really a receptor
for metallic taste or it's nothing
but this magical combination
of the activation of the existing lines,
think of it as lines of information,
just separate lines,
like the keys of a piano.
Sweet, sour, bitter, salt, umami,
you play the key and you
activate a one chord.
And that one chord in the case
of a piano leads to a note,
you know a tune and in the case
of taste leads to an
action and a behavior,
but you play many of them together.
And something emerges
that it's different than
any one of the pieces.
And it's possible that
metallic, for example,
represents the combination
of the activity just
in the right ratio makes
of these other lines.
- Makes sense.
And it actually provides a perfect,
your example of the piano provides
a perfect segue for what
I'd like to touch on next,
which is if you would
describe the sequence
of neural events leading to
a perceptual event of taste.
And I'm certain that somewhere
in there you'll embed
an answer to the question of whether
or not we indeed have
different taste receptors
distributed in different
locations on our tongue.
Or elsewhere in the mouth.
- Yes.
So let's start by the banking
that old tale and myth.
- Who came up with that?
- There are many views,
but the most prevalent is that
there was an original drawing
describing the sensitivity
of the tongue to different tastes.
So imagine I can take a Q-Tip,
this is a thought experiment,
and I'm going to dip that
Q-Tip in salt and in quinine
as something bitter and
glucose as something sweet.
And I'm going to take that Q-tip,
ask you to stick your tongue out
and start moving around
your tongue and ask you,
what do you feel?
And then I'm going to
change the concentration
of the amount of salt or the
amount of bitter and ask,
can I get some sort of
a map of sensitivity
to the different tastes?
And the argument that
has emerged is that there
is a good likelihood that the data
was simply mistranslated
as it was being drawn.
And of course, that led
to an entire industry.
This is the way you maximize
your wine experience,
because now we're going to form the vessel
that you're going to drink from
so that it acts maximally on
the receptors which happen.
Now, there is no tongue map.
All right, we have taste buds distributed
in various parts of the tongue.
So there is a map on the
distribution of taste bud,
but each taste bud has around
a hundred taste receptor cells.
And those taste receptor
cells can be of five types,
sweet, sour, bitter, salty, or umami.
And for the most part,
all taste buds have the representation
of all five taste qualities.
Now there's no question
that there is a slight bias
for some taste, like bitter,
is particularly rich at the
very back of your tongue.
And there is a teleological
basis for that,
actually a biological basis for that.
That's the last line of defense
before you swallow something bad.
And so let's make sure that
the very back of your tongue
has plenty of these bad news receptors
so that if they get activated,
you can trigger a gagging reflex
and get rid of this that
otherwise may kill you.
- Makes good sense.
- But the notion that all sweet is
in the front and salt is on the side.
It's not real.
Go ahead.
- Oh, I was just going
to ask, first of all,
thank you for dispelling that myth.
And we will propagate
that information as
far and wide as we can.
'Cause I think that's the number
one myth related to taste.
The other one is,
are there taste receptors
anywhere else in the mouth,
for instance, on the lips?
- The palette, the palette, not the lips.
So it's in the pharynx at the
very back of the oral cavity,
the tongue and the palette and the palette
is very rich in sweet receptors.
- I'll have to pay attention to this
the next time I eat something sweet.
- When you pull it up, yeah.
Now the important thing is that
after the receptors for
these five, the detectors,
the molecules that send sweet,
sour, bitter, salt, umami,
these are receptors,
proteins found on the surface
of taste receptor cells that
interact with these chemicals.
And once they interact,
then they trigger the cascade
of events, biochemical events,
inside cell that now
sends an electrical signal
that says there is sweet
here, or there is salt here.
Now having these receptors
and my laboratory identify
the receptors for all
five basic taste classes,
sweet, bitter, salt, umami,
and most recently sour.
Now completing the palette.
You can now use these
receptors to really map
where are they found in the
tongue in a very rigorous way.
This is no longer about using a Q-Tip
and trying to figure
out what you're feeling,
but rather what you have in your tongue.
This is not a guess.
This is now a physical map that says
the sweet receptors are found here.
The bitter are found here.
And when you do that,
you find that in fact,
every taste bud throughout
your oral cavity
has receptors for all of
the basic taste classes.
- Amazing.
And as it turns out,
and I'm sure you'll tell us
important in terms of thinking
about how the brain computes,
encodes and decodes this
thing we call taste.
I'm going to inject a quick
question that I'm sure is on
many people's minds before we get back
into the biological circuit,
which is many people, including myself,
are familiar with the
experience of drinking
a sip of tea or coffee that is too hot,
and burning my tongue is
the way I would describe it.
- Horrible.
And then disrupting my sense of taste
for some period of time afterward.
When I experienced that phenomenon,
that unfortunate phenomenon have
I destroyed taste
receptors that regenerate,
or have I somehow used temperature
to distort the function of the circuit
so that I no longer taste
the way I did before?
- Excellent question.
And the answer is both.
It turns out that your taste receptors
only live for around two
weeks, and this, by the way,
makes sense because here you
have an organ, the tongue,
that is continuously exposed to everything
you could range from the nicest,
to the most horrible possible things.
- Use your imagination.
- And so you need to make sure
that these cells are always coming back
in a way that can reexperience the world
in the right way and
there are other organs
that have the same underlying logic.
Your gut, your intestines
are the same way.
Amazing.
Again, they're receiving
everything that you ingest.
God forbid what's there, from the spiciest
to the most horrible tastings
or the most delicious.
And again,
those intestinal cells
whose role is to ultimately
take all these nutrients and
bring them into the body.
Also renew in a very, very fast cycle,
olfactory neurons in
your nose is the example.
So then A, yes,
you're burning a lot of your
cells and is over for those.
The good news is that
they're going to come back,
but we know that when you
burn yourself with tea,
they come back within 20 minutes,
30 minutes, an hour,
and these cells are not
renewing in that timeframe.
They're not listening to your needs.
They have their own internal clock.
And so you are really affecting,
you're damaging them in a
way that they can recover.
And then they come back
and you also damage your
somatosensory cells.
These are the results that
feel things, not taste things.
And then you wait half an hour or so,
and then my goodness, thank
God, it's back to normal.
- And most of the time,
I don't even notice the
transition realizing,
as you tell me, and I'll later,
I'll ask you about the relationship
between odor and taste.
But as a next step, along this circuit,
let's assume I ingest
some, let's keep it simple.
A sweet taste.
- Let's make it even simpler.
But at the same time,
perhaps more informative,
let's compare and
contrast sweet and bitter
as we follow their lines
from the tongue to the brain.
So the first thing is that
the two evoke diametrically
opposed behaviors.
If we have to come up with
two sensory experience
that represent polar opposites,
it will be sweet and video.
There are not two colors that
represent polar opposites
because you could say black and white,
they are polar opposites,
one detects only one thing.
The other one detects everything,
but they don't evoke different behaviors.
- Even political parties
have some overlap.
- Sweet and bitter are
the two opposite ends
of the sensory spectrum,
now, a taste can be
defined by two features.
Again, I'm a reductionist,
so I'm reducing it in a way that I think
it's easier to follow the signal.
And the two features are
its quality and its valance
and valance with a little V
that's what we say in Spanish, with a V,
means the value of that experience, right?
Or in this case of that
stimuli and you take sweet,
sweet has a quality, an identity,
and that's what you and I will refer
to as the taste of sweet.
We know exactly what it tastes like,
But sweet also has a positive valance,
which makes it incredibly
attractive and appetitive,
but it's attractive and appetitive,
as I'll tell you in a second independent
of its identity and quality.
In fact, we have been able
to engineer animals where we completely
remove the valance from the stimuli.
So these animals can taste sweet,
can recognize it as sweet,
but it's no longer attractive.
It's just one more chemical stimuli.
And that's because the
identity and the valence
are encoded in two separate
parts of the brain.
In the case of bitter,
again, it has on the
one hand its identity,
its quality, and you know
exactly what bitter tastes like.
- I can taste it now,
even as you describe it.
- But it also has a valence and that's
a negative valance because
it evokes aversive behaviors.
Are we on?
- Absolutely.
And it comes to mind.
I remember telling some kids recently
that we're going to go get ice
cream and it was interesting.
They looked up and they started smacking
their like, they'll actually.
- The anticipatory response.
Absolutely.
When we talk about the gut
brain maybe we'll get there.
So then the signals, if we
follow now, these two lines,
they're really like two separate keys
at the two ends of this keyboard.
And you press one key and
you activate this cord.
So you activate the sweet cells
throughout your oral cavity.
And they all converge into
a group of sweet neurons
in the next station, which
is still outside the brain,
it's one of the taste ganglia.
These are the neurons
that innervate your tongue
and the oral cavity.
- Where do they sit approximately?
- Around there.
- Right here around there.
The lymph nodes, more or less?
- You got it.
And there are two main
ganglia that innervate
the vast majority of all
taste buds in the oral cavity.
And then from there that sweet signal
goes onto the brain stem.
The brain stem is the entry
of the body into the brain.
And there are different
areas of the brain stem.
And there are different groups
of neurons in the brain stem.
And there's this unique area in a unique,
a topographically defined
location in the rostral side
of the brain that receives
all of the taste input.
- A very dense area of the brain.
- A very rich area of the brain.
Exactly.
And from there,
the sweet signal goes to this other area
higher up on the brain stem.
And then it goes through
a number of stations where
that sweet signal goes from
sweet neuron to sweet neuron,
to sweet neuron, to
eventually get to your cortex.
And once it gets to your taste cortex,
that's where meaning is
imposed into that signal.
It's then, and only then this is what
the data suggests that now you
can identify this as a sweet stimuli.
- [Andrew] And how quickly
does that all happen?
- You know, the time scale of
the nervous system it's fast.
- So within less than a second.
- [Charles] Yeah, absolutely.
- I rarely mistake bitter for sweet.
Maybe with respect to people
and my own poor judgment,
but not with respect to taste.
- And in fact,
we can demonstrate this
because we can stick electrodes
at each of these stations, conceptually,
and we can stimulate the tongue,
and then we can record
the signals pretty much
time log the stimulus delivery.
You deliver the stimuli and
within a fraction of a second,
you see now the response
in this following stations,
now it gets to the cortex,
and now in there you impose
meaning to that taste.
There is an area of your
brain that represents
the taste of sweet in taste cortex
and a different area that
represents the taste of bitter.
In a sense, there is a topographic map
of these taste qualities
inside your brain.
Now we're going to do
a thought experiment.
Now, if this group of neurons
in your cortex really represents
the sense of sweet and
this added different group
of neurons in your brain
represents the taste,
the perception of bitter,
then we should be able to do two things.
First, I should be able
to go into your brain,
somehow silence those neurons,
find a way to prevent
them from being activated.
And I can give you all the sweet you want,
and you'll never know
that you're tasting sweet.
And conversely, I should be
able to go into your brain,
come up with a way to
activate those neurons
while I'm giving you absolutely nothing.
And you're going to think
that you are getting
that full percept and that's
precisely what we have done.
And that's precisely what you get.
This of course is in the brain of mice.
- But presumably in humans
it would work similarly.
- Absolutely the same, zero doubt.
I have no questions.
So this attests to two important things,
the first to the predetermined
nature of the sense of taste,
because it means I can go to these parts
of your brain in the
absence of any stimuli.
And have you throw the
full behavioral experience.
In fact, when we activate in your cortex,
these bitter neurons, the
animal can start gagging,
but it's drinking only water,
but the animal thinks that's
getting a bitter stimuli.
[audience applauds] This is amazing.
- And so, and the second,
just to finish the line so
that it doesn't sound
like it teaches two things
and then I only give you one lesson.
It is that it substantiates
this capacity of the brain to segregate,
to separate in this nodes of action,
the representation of these
two diametrically opposed percepts.
Which is sweet, for
example, versus bitter.
- The reason I say amazing,
and that is also amazing is the following,
you told us earlier, and
you're absolutely correct,
of course, that the end of the day,
whether or not it's one
group of neurons over here,
and another group of neurons over there,
which is the way it turns out to be,
electrical activity is the generic,
common language of both sets of neurons.
So that raises the question for me,
of whether or not those
separate sets of neurons
are connected to areas of the brain
that create this sense
of valence or whether
or not they're simply
created connected, excuse me,
to sets of neurons that evoke
distinct behaviors of moving
towards and inhaling more
and licking or aversive are
we essentially interpreting our behavior
and our micro responses
or are micro responses
and our behaviors the
consequence of the percept?
- Excellent, excellent question.
So first answer is they go into
an area of the brain
where valence is imposed,
and that area is known as the
amygdala and the sweet neurons
go to a different area
than the bitter neurons.
Now I want to do a thought experiment
because I think your audience
might appreciate this.
Let's say I activate this group of neurons
and the animal increases licking
and I'm activating the sweet neurons.
And so that's expected
because now it's tasting
this water as if it was sugar.
Now this Moses transforming
water into wine
in this case we're going
to, and today's Passover,
so this is an appropriate example,
we're transforming it into sweet.
But how do I know that
activating them is evoking
a positive feeling inside,
a goodness, a satisfaction,
or I love it versus I'm
just increasing licking,
which is the other option,
because all we're seeing is
that the animal is leaking more.
And we're trying to infer that that means
that he's feeling something
really good versus you know what,
that piano line is going back
straight into the tongue.
And all it's doing is
forcing it to move faster.
Well, we can actually separate this
by doing experiments that allows
to fundamentally distinguish them
and imagine the following experiment,
I'm going to take the
animal and I'm going to
put them inside a box that has two sides.
And the two sides have features
that make him different.
One has yellow little toys.
The other one has green toys.
One has little black stripes.
The other one has blue stripes.
So the animal can tell the
two halves, I take the mouse,
put them inside this
arena, this play arena.
And it will explore and potter
around both sides with equal frequency.
And now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to activate these neurons,
these sweet neurons,
every time the animal
is on the side with the yellow stripes.
And if that is creating a
positive internal state,
what would the animal now want to do?
It will want to stay on the
side with the yellow stripes.
There's no licking here.
The animal is not extending its tongue
every time I'm activating this neurons.
This is known as a place preference test.
And it's generally used,
it's just one form of many
different tests to demonstrate
that the activation of a group
of neurons in the brain is imposing,
for example, a positive
versus a negative valance.
Whereas if I do the same thing
by activating the bitter neurons,
the animal will actively
want now to stay away
from the side where these
neurons are being activated.
- And that's precisely what you see.
- [Charles] And that's
precisely what we see.
- Many people, including myself,
are familiar with the experience
of going to a restaurant,
eating a variety of foods.
And then fortunately
doesn't happen that often,
but then feeling very sick.
I learned coming up in neuroscience
that this is one strong
example of one trial learning,
that from that point on,
it's not the restaurant
or the waitress or waiter,
or the date,
but it's my notion of it
had to have been the shrimp
that leads me to then want to
avoid shrimp in every context,
maybe even shrimp powder.
- You got it.
- For a very long time.
I can imagine all the evolutionarily
adaptive reasons why this
such a phenomenon would exist.
Do we have any concept of where
in this pathway it exists?
- We do, we know actually
a significant amount
at a general level.
In fact, more than shrimp,
oysters are even a more dramatic example,
one bad oyster is all
you need to be driven
that way for the next six months.
- I think because the
texture alone is something
that one learns to overcome.
I actually really enjoy oysters.
I despise mussels, despise
shrimp, not the animal,
but the taste and yet
oysters, for some reason,
I've yet to have a bad experience.
- It's like, uni, by the way
texture is hard to get
over, but once you get over,
it's delicious.
- That's what they tell me.
We were both in San Diego at one point,
and I'll give a plug to Sushi Ota,
is kind of the famous place,
and they have amazing uni
and I've tried it twice.
And I'm oh for two.
It somehow the texture outweighs
any kind of the deliciousness
that people report.
- It's a very acquired taste.
It's like beer, I grew up in Chile,
that's where the accent comes
from in case anyone wonder.
And by the time I came
here to graduate school,
I was 19, too old to overcome
my heavy Chilian accent.
So here I am, 40 years, 50 years late,
not quite 40 plus-
- We appreciate it.
- And I still sound like
I just came off the boat.
So in Chile, you don't drink
beer when you're young,
you drink wine.
Chili's a huge wine producer.
So when I came to the US,
all of my classmates were
drinking beer because
they had finished college
where they were all
you're drinking and graduate school,
you're working 18 hours a day every day,
the way they relax, let's
go and have some beers.
- And beer is cheaper.
- And beer is cheap,
and we were being clearly
underpaid may I add.
I couldn't do it.
It's an acquired taste.
It was too late by then.
And here I am 60 plus.
And if you take all the beer
I've drank in my entire life,
I would say they add to less than
an eight ounce glass of water.
- Impressive.
Well, your health is
probably better for it.
- I'm not sure.
- Your physical health anyway.
- So it goes back to acquired taste.
This is the connection
to uni and to oysters.
Now, going back to the one trial learning
this is the great thing about our brains,
certain things we need to repeat
a hundred times to learn
them, hello operator.
Can I have the phone number
for sushi Ota, please?
And then she'll give it
to you over the phone,
at least in the old days.
And then you need to
repeat it to yourself over
and over and over, over the next minute.
So you can dial sushi Ota,
and five minutes later, it's gone.
That's what we call working memory.
Then there is the short term memory.
We park our car.
And if we're lucky, by the end of the day,
we remember where it is.
And then there is the long term memory.
We remember the birthdays of every one
of our children for the rest of our lives.
Well, there are events that a
single event is so traumatic
that it activates the circuits in a way
that it's a one trial learning.
And the taste system is literally
at the top of that food chain.
And there is a phenomenon known
as conditioned taste aversion.
You can pair an attractive
stimuli with a really bad one,
and you can make an animal begin
to vehemently dislike for example, sugar.
And that's because you've
conditioned the animals
to now be averse to these
otherwise nice taste
because it's been associated with malaise.
And when you do that,
now you could begin to ask
why has change in the signal
as it travels from the tongue
to the brain in a normal animal
versus an animal where you
have now transformed sweet
from being attractive to being immersive.
And this is the way now
you begin to explore
how the brain changes,
the nature, the quality,
the meaning of a stimuli
as a function of its state.
- I have a number of
questions related to that,
all of which relate to
this idea of context,
because you mentioned before
that flavor is distinct
from taste because flavor involves smell,
texture, temperature,
and some other features,
uni, sea urchin being a good example of,
I can sense the texture.
It actually it's, nah, I won't describe
what it reminds me of,
for various reasons.
The ability to place context into,
to insert context into a perception,
or rather to insert a perception
into context is so powerful.
And there's an element of
kind of mystery about it.
But if we start to think
about some of the more nuance
that we like to live at
the edge, as you say,
how many different
tastes on the taste dial
to go back to your analogy
earlier, the color dial,
do you think that there
could be for something
as fixed as bitter, so for instance,
I don't think I like bitter taste,
but I like some fermented foods
that seem to have a little
bit of sour and have a little bit
of that briny flavor.
How much plasticity do
you think there is there
and in particular across the lifespan,
because I think one of
the most salient examples
of this is that kids don't seem
to like certain vegetables,
but they all are hardwired
to like sweet tastes.
And yet you could also imagine
that one of the reasons
why they may eventually grow
to incorporate vegetables is
because of some knowledge
that vegetables might be-
- Good for you.
- Better for them.
So is there a change in the
receptors, the distribution,
the number, the sensitivity, et cetera,
that can explain the transition
from wanting to avoid vegetables,
to being willing to eat vegetables
simply in childhood to early development.
Yes, so I going to take the
question slightly differently,
but I think it would illustrate the point.
And I want to just
use the difference between
the olfactory system
and the taste system to make the point,
taste system five basic pallets,
sweet, sour, bitter, salt, umami,
each of them has a predetermined identity.
We know exactly what and valence.
These are attractive.
These are aversive.
In the olfactory system,
it's claimed that we can smell millions
of different odors, yet for the most part,
none of them have an innate
predetermined meaning,
in olfactory system,
meaning is imposed by
learning and experience.
- Even the smell of smoke?
- So I'm going to give you,
I'm going to make it differently.
They are a handful of the millions
of odors that were claimed that,
that you could immediately tell me these
are adversive and these are attractive.
- Vomit.
- So vomit, it's not correct
because I can assure you that they're
cultures and societies where
things which are far less
appealing than vomit do not
evoke a adverse reaction.
- Really?
- Really, sulfur would
be maybe a universal.
I'm not talking pheromones.
pheromones are in a different category
that trigger innate responses,
but nearly every other is afforded meaning
by learning and experience.
And that's why you like broccoli.
And I despise broccoli because I remember
my mother forcing me to eat broccoli.
[audience applauds] I'm so sorry.
- Same sensory experience.
This accommodates two important things.
In the case of taste,
you have neurons at every
station that are for sweet,
for sour, for bitter,
for salty, and umami,
it's only five classes.
So it's not going to
take a lot of your brain.
If we can, in fact,
smell a million others,
and everyone else of others
had to have predetermined,
meaning there's not
going to be enough brain
just to accommodate that one sense.
And so evolution in its infinite wisdom,
evolved a system where you put together
a pathway and a cortex, olfactory cortex,
where you have the capacity
to associate every other
in a specific context that
now gives it the meaning.
Now let's go back to the
original question then.
So other than clearly
plastic, mega plastic,
because it's fundamental
basis and neural organization,
but taste,
we just told you that
predetermined, hardwired,
but predetermined, hardwired doesn't mean
that it's not modulated
by learning or experience.
It only means that you
are born liking sweet
and disliking bitter.
And we have many examples of plasticity,
beer being one example.
So why do we learn to
love beer and coffee.
It's because it has an
associated gain to the system
and that gain to the system,
that positive valance
that emerges out of that negative signal
is sufficient to create
that positive association.
And in the case of beer,
of course, it's alcohol.
The feeling good that we get after
is more than sufficient to say,
I want to have more of this.
And in the case of coffee, of course,
is caffeine activating a whole
group of neurotransmitter
systems that give you that
high associated with coffee.
So yes, this taste system is changeable.
It's malleable, and it's subject subjected
to learning and experience.
But I like the olfactory
system is restricted
in what you could do with it
because its goal is to allow you
to get nutrients and survive.
The goal of the olfactory
system is very different.
It's being used, not in our case,
but in every animal species
to identify friend versus foe,
to identify mate,
to identify ecological
niches they want to be in.
So it plays a very broad
role that then requires
that it be set up organized
and function in a very
different type of context.
Taste is about, can we get the
nutrients we need to survive?
And can we ensure that we are
attracted to the ones we need?
And we adverse to the ones
that are going to kill us,
I'm being overly simplistic
and reductionist.
But I think it illustrates
the huge difference
between these two chemo sensory systems.
- I don't think you're
being overly simplicity.
I think it illustrates
the key intractable nature of this system
and the way you've approached it.
And I think it's important
for people to hear that,
because everybody,
as we are as mystified with
empathy and love, et cetera.
So in a fairness to that,
I'm going to ask a sort of
a high level question
or abstract question.
This was based on a conversation I had
with a former girlfriend
where we were talking about
chemistry between individuals.
Very complicated topic on the one hand.
But on the other hand, quite
simple in that certain people,
for whatever reason, evoke a
tremendous sense of arousal,
for lack of a better
word, between two people,
one would hope,
at least for some period of time.
- I didn't know this was
that kind of a podcast.
- No, well, the reason I,
but this has to do with taste
because she said something,
I think in part to
maybe irritate me a bit,
but we were commenting not
about our own experience of each other,
but of someone that she
was now very excited
about we're on good terms.
And she said, "What do you think it is,
this thing of chemistry?"
So maybe she was trying to-
- Warn you of what's coming.
- Warn me what's coming.
And she said,
"I have a feeling something
about it is in smell
and something about it
is actually in taste,
literally the taste of somebody's breath."
That's the way she described it.
And I thought that it was
a very interesting example
for a number of reasons,
but in particular,
because it gets to the
merging of odor and taste.
But also to the idea that
of course the context
of a new relationship, I'm
assuming that, and in fact,
they're both attractive people, et cetera.
There's a whole context there,
but I've had the experience of the odor
of somebody's breath being aversive.
Not because I could
identify it as aversive.
- Because you just didn't like it.
- But because I just didn't like it.
- But that's because you associated
with added odors that trigger
that negative aversive
reaction, by the way.
- Absolutely.
There are certain perfumes
to me that are aversive.
- [Charles] You got it.
- And there are other sense,
I can recall a sense of skin, of foods,
et cetera, that are immensely appetitive.
So I've experienced both
sides of this equation myself.
And she was describing this
and to me more than tasting wine,
which is the typical example
where people inhale it and
then they drink it, to me,
this seems like something
that more people might
be able to relate to,
that certain things and
people smell delicious.
Even mothers describing the
smell of their baby's head.
- A mother, or us.
- [Andrew] Of course, men too, yeah.
- I mean our own babies
when in their necks,
that's the magical place.
- Their neck.
- The back of their neck.
- There you go.
- Oh my goodness.
I have a grandchild now.
So I know exactly what, Rio,
that's his name, smells like.
- Okay.
So more beautiful examples.
It's always more fun to think
about the beautiful positively
appetitive examples.
The smell of the back
of your grandson's neck.
I mean, you could get
more specific than that,
but not a lot more specific exactly.
So what is going on in terms
of the combination of odor
and taste given that these
two systems are so different?
- Yes, and they come together,
ultimately there is a place
in the brain where they come
together to integrate the two into
what we would call that
sensory experience.
And I'll tell you an experiment
that you could do that demonstrates this.
I think it's good for the,
for your audience here to get
a sense of how we approach
these problems so that we can get
in a meaningful scientific answers.
So we know where the olfactory
cortex is in the brain.
We know where the taste
They're in two different places.
We can go to each of these two, cortexes,
put color traces, we put green in one,
we put red in the other and
we see where the colors go to.
That's a reflection of where
those neurons are projecting
into their next targets.
Once they get the signal, where
do they send the signal to?
And then we reason that if odor
and taste come together
somewhere in the brain,
we should find an area that now
it's getting red and green color.
And we found such an area.
And next we anticipated,
we hypothesized that
maybe this is the area
in the brain of the mouse,
corresponding area in the brain of humans,
that integrates odor and taste.
It's known as,
the term normally used is
multisensory integration.
And if this is true, we could
do the following experiment.
We can train a mouse
to lick sweet.
And if they guess correctly,
that that is supposed to be sweet.
They should go now to the
right port, to the right side,
to get a water reward.
If they go to the lift, when it was sweet,
then they're incorrect
and they get no reward
and they actually get a time out.
Now the mice are thirsty,
so they're very motivated to perform.
And if you repeat this
task a hundred times,
a hundred trials, incredibly enough,
this animal learned to recognize the sweet
and execute the right action.
And by their action,
we now are being told what
that animal is tasting.
We can make it more interesting
and we can give him
sweet and bitter and say,
if it's sweet go to the right
and if it's bitter go to the left.
And after you train him
this mice with 90% accuracy,
it'll tell you, when you
randomize now the stimuli,
what was sweet and what was bitter?
We can now do the same experiment,
but now mix taste with odor and say,
if you got odor alone,
go to the right or push
this lever in mice.
If you get taste alone,
go to this other part or
push this other lever.
And if you get the two together,
do this something else.
And if you train the mice,
the mice are able now to
report back to you when it's
sensing taste alone,
odor alone, or the mix.
Makes sense?
- Makes sense.
- Now we can go to the
brain of this mice and go
to this area that we now uncover,
discover as being the side
of multisensory integration
between taste and odor, and silence it,
prevent it from being
activated experimentally.
And if that area really represented
the integration of these two,
the animals should still be able
to recognize the taste alone.
They still should be able to
recognize the other alone,
but should be incapable
now to recognize the mix,
and exactly as predicted.
That's exactly what you get.
All right?
- The brain is basically
a series of engineered circuits, complex.
- You got it.
And our task is to figure
out how can we extract
this amazing architecture
of these circuits
in a way that we can begin to uncover
the mysteries of the brain.
- And why certain people's
breath tastes so good
and other people's not so good.
- Exactly.
So I never answered that,
but I told you how we can figure out
where in the brain it's happening.
- As we've been having this discussion,
I thought a few times about similarities
to the visual system or
differences to the visual system,
the visual system,
there are a couple of
phenomenon that I wonder
if they also exist in the taste system,
and the visual system
we know for instance,
that if you look at something long enough
and activate the given
receptors long enough,
that object will actually disappear.
We offset this with little
micro eye movements,
et cetera, but the principle
is a fundamental one.
This habituation or desensitization,
everyone seems to call
it something different,
but you get the idea of course,
in the taste system,
I'm certainly familiar
with eating something very,
very sweet for the first
time in a long time.
And it feel tastes very
sweet, but a few more licks,
a few more bites,
and now it tastes not as
sweet, with olfaction,
I'm familiar with the odor
in a room I don't like,
or I like, and then it disappearing.
So similar phenomena,
where does that occur?
And can you imagine a sort of a system
by which people could leverage that?
Because I do think that
most people are interested
in eating, not more sugar, but less sugar.
- I think we have better
ways to approach that.
And we can transition from
taste into these other circuits
that makes sugar so extraordinarily
impossible not to consume.
- Impossible, exactly.
- So where does the desensitizing happen.
That's the term that we use, and it's,
I think happening at multiple stations,
it's happening at the receptor level.
I.e. the salt in your tongue
that are sensing the sugar,
as you activate this receptor
and it's triggering activity
after activity after activity,
eventually you exhaust the receptor again,
I'm using terms which are
extraordinarily loose.
- But for sake of this discussion.
- For the sake of this
discussion the receptor
gets to a point where he
undergoes a set of changes,
chemical changes, where it now
signals far less efficiently,
or it even gets removed from
the surface of the cell.
And now what will happen
is that the same amount
of sugar will trigger
far less of a response.
And that is a huge side
of this modulation.
And then the next, I believe
is the integrated again,
loss of signaling that happens
by continuous activation
of the circuit at each of these
different neural stations.
You know, there is from
the tongue to the ganglia,
from the ganglia to the first station
in the brain stem, a second
station in the brain stem,
to the thalamus, then to the cortex.
So there are multiple steps
that this signal is traveling.
Now, you might say why,
if this is a label line,
why do you need to have so many stations?
And that's because the taste
system is so important to
ensure that you get what
you need to survive,
that it has to be subjected
to modulation by the internal state.
And each of these nodes
provides a new site
to give it plasticity and modulation,
not necessarily to change the
way that something tastes,
but to ensure that you consume more
or less or differently of what you need.
I'm going to give you one example
of how the internal state changes
the way the taste system works.
Salt is very appetitive
at low concentrations.
And that's because we need it.
It's our electro lite
balance requires salt.
Every one of our neurons uses salt
as the most important of the ions
with potassium to ensure
that you can transfer
these electrical signals
within and between neurons,
but at high concentrations,
let's say ocean water,
it's incredibly aversive.
And we all know this because
we are going to the ocean.
And then when you get it in
your mouth, it's not that great.
However, if I salt deprive
you, and we can do this
in experimental models quite readily,
now this incredibly high
concentration of salt,
one molar sodium chloride becomes
amazingly appetitive and attractive.
What's going on in here.
Your tongue is telling
you, this is horrible,
but your brain is telling
you, I don't care.
You need it.
And this is what we call the modulation
of the taste system by the internal state.
- And presumably if one is hungry enough,
even uni will taste good.
Just hit you hit it right on the money.
No, no, this is exactly correct.
Or if you're thirsty and hungry,
you suppress hunger so that you don't
waste water molecules in digesting food.
Why?
Because if you're thirsty
and you have no water,
you will die within a week or so,
but you can on a hunger strike as long
as you have water for months,
because you're going to eat
up all your energy reserves.
Water is a different story.
So you could see,
or that there are multiple layers
at which the taste system that guides
our drive and our motivation to consume
the nutrients we need has to be modulated
in response to the internal state.
And of course,
internal state itself has
to be modulated by the external world.
And so that I think is a reason
why, what could otherwise,
would've been an incredibly simple system
from the tongue to the
cortex in one just wire.
It's not, because you have to ensure
that each step you give the system
that level of flexibility
or what we call in
neuroscience, plasticity.
- I think we're headed into the gut.
But I have a question that has just been
on my mind for a bit now,
because I was drinking this water
and it has essentially no taste.
Is there any kind of signal for
the absence of taste despite
having something in the
mouth and here is why I ask,
what I'm thinking about is saliva.
And while it's true that if
I eat a lot of very highly
palatable foods that does change
how I experience more bland foods,
I must confess when I eat a
lot of these highly processed
foods I don't particularly like them.
I tend to crave healthier foods,
but that's probably for contextual
reasons about nutrients,
et cetera.
But I could imagine an experiment where-
- You see a taste of no taste.
- Right, is there a taste of no taste,
because in the visual system there is.
You close the eyes and you
start getting increases in
activity in the visual system,
as opposed to decreases,
which often surprises people.
But there are reasons for that
because everything is about
signal to noise, signal to background.
- It's a good question.
I can tell you that most of
our work is trying to focus on
how the taste system works,
not how it doesn't work well,
but you know.
- Yeah, I know you're being playful.
And I knew when inviting you here today,
I was setting myself up for,
actually on a different-
- We're trying to learn things.
- Yeah, I know.
- However-
- All right, listen, I was
weaned in this system of a,
and I'll say it here for the second.
Actually I recorded a podcast
recently with a very prominent
podcast with Lex Friedman Podcast.
And I made reference to the so-called
New York neuroscience mafia.
I won't say whether or not we
are sitting in the presence of
the New York neuroscience
mafia member, but in any event,
I know the sorts of ribbing
that they provide for those listening,
this is the kind of hazing that happens.
Benevolent hazing in academia.
I'm the target.
- Of course, it's-
- It's a sign of love.
- Exactly.
- He's going to tell me that.
- And it's always about the
science in the end, right.
But it's an interesting question.
Look, I am,
I don't know the answer
and I don't even know how
I would explore it in a way
that it will rigorously teach me, eh, but.
- Let me tell you why I'm asking.
And then I'll offer an experiment
that I'd love to see
someone here in the lab do.
I'm thinking about saliva.
- No, no, no, but that we know,
that we can figure it out.
- Obviously.
But the question is whether or
not the saliva in a fed state
is distinct from the
saliva in an unfed state,
such that it modulates the
sensitivity, the response.
- It's not the sensitivity,
the experiment has been done.
- [Andrew] It has been done.
And so the answer is no.
- It's not.
And the way you could do the experiment is
because we use artificial saliva.
- There's such a thing?
I know there's artificial tears, but.
- No, no, we,
I don't mean that you go to
Walgreens that you get, I mean,
we, in my laboratory,
we know the composition of saliva
and so you can make such a thing,
and you can take taste cells in culture
or in a tongue where you wash it out,
and then you can apply artificial saliva.
And what happens is that the system
is being engineered to desensitize,
to become agnostic for
saliva to become invisible.
And there is no difference
on the state of the animal.
- Great, well, this is the
reason to do experiments.
- [Charles] Yeah, absolutely.
- So it doesn't defeat
any grand hypothesis.
It's just a pure curiosity.
- You know that curiosity kills the cat?
- I do,
but saves the career of a
scientists every single time.
- That's what drives us, absolutely.
- Every single time.
- It's the story of our lives.
- Exactly.
So if it's not saliva
and apparently it is not,
what about internal state
and what aspects of this,
the internal milieu are relevant
because there's autonomic,
there's a sleep and awake, there's stress.
One of the questions that
I got from hundreds of people
when I solicited questions in
advance of this episode was why do
I crave sugar when I'm
stressed, for instance,
and that could be contextual,
but what are the basic elements-
- Because it makes us
feel good by the way,
we'll get to that.
That's his answer.
- Soothing.
- It activates,
what I'm going to generically
refer to as reward pleasure
centers in a way that it dramatically,
changes our internal state.
This is in why do we
eat a gallon ice cream
when we're very depressed?
In fact, this is a good segue to go
into this an entire different world
of the body telling your brain
what you need in important
things like sugar and fat,
but anyways, go ahead, you
were going to ask something.
- Well, no, I would like to discuss
the most basic elements of
internal state in particular,
the ones that are below
our conscious detection.
And this is a,
of course is a segue into
this incredible landscape,
which is the gut brain axis,
which I think 15 years ago was almost a,
maybe it was posters at a meeting.
And then now I believe you and others,
there are companies, there have companies,
there are active research programs,
and beautiful work.
Maybe you could describe some of that work
that you and others have been involved in.
And a lot of the listeners of
this podcast will have heard
of the gut brain axis.
And there are a lot of misconceptions
about the gut brain axis.
Many people think that this
means that we think with our
stomach because of the quote
unquote, gut feeling aspect,
but I'd love for you to talk
about the aspects of gut brain
signaling that drive or
change our perceptions
and behaviors that are
completely beneath our awareness.
- Yes. Excellent.
So let me begin maybe by stating that,
the brain needs to monitor
the state of every one of our organs,
it has to do it.
This is the only way that the
brain can ensure that every
one of those organs are working
together in a way that we
have healthy physiology.
Now,
this monitoring of the brain
has been known for a long time,
but I think what hadn't been
fully appreciated that this is
a two-way highway where the
brain is not only monitoring,
but is now modulating back
what the body needs to do.
And that includes all the way
from monitoring the frequency
of heartbeats and the way that
inspiration and aspirations
in the breeding cycle operate
to what happens when you
ingest sugar and fat.
Now, let me give you an example again,
of how the brain can take
what we would refer to contextual
associations and transform
it into incredible changes
in physiology and metabolism.
Remember Pavlov?
So Pavlov in his classical
experiments in conditioning,
associative conditioning,
he would take a bell,
he would ring the bell every time
he was going to feed the dog.
And eventually the dog
learned to associate
the ringing of the bell with food coming.
Now, the first incredible finding
he made is the fact that the dog now
in the presence of the bell alone
will start to salivate.
And we will call that
neurologically speaking
an anticipatory response.
Okay, I could understand it.
I get it.
You know, neurons in the brain that form
that association now
represent food is coming.
And they're sending a signal
to motor neurons to go into
your salivary glands to squeeze them.
So you release saliva because
you know food is coming,
but what's even more remarkable
is that those animals are
also releasing insulin
in response to a bell.
Okay.
This illustrates one part
of this two-way highway,
the highway going down,
somehow the brain created these
associations and there are
neurons in your brain now that
no food is coming and send a
signal somehow all the way down
to your pancreas that now it
says release insulin because
sugar is coming down.
This goes back to the magic of the brain.
It's a never ending source
of both joy and intrigue.
How the hell do they do this?
I mean, the neurons.
- I share your delight and fascination.
There's not a day or a lecture
or some talks are better than
others or talk where I don't
sit back and just think,
it's absolutely amazing.
- How.
- It's amazing.
- Now over the past, I don't know,
dozen years it and with great force
over the last five years
now, the main highway
that is communicating
the state of the body with the brain,
it has been uncovered as being
what we now refer to
as the gut brain axis.
And the highway is a
specific bundle of nerves
which emerged from the Vagal
ganglia, the nodus ganglia.
And so it's the vagus
nerve that is innervating
the majority of the organs in your body.
It's monitoring their function,
sending a signal to the brain.
And now the brain going
back down and saying,
this is going alright, do this,
or this is not going too well, do that.
- And I should point out as
you well know, every organ,
spleen, pancreas, lung.
- They all must be monitored.
In fact I now,
I have no doubt that the
diseases that we have normally
associated with metabolism, physiology,
and even immunity are likely
to emerge as diseases,
conditions, states of the brain.
I don't think obesity is
a disease of metabolism.
I believe obesity is a
disease of brain circuits.
- [Andrew] I do as well.
- And so this view that we have,
been working on for the
longest time, because,
the molecules that we're
dealing with are in the body,
not in the head, led us to to view,
of course this issues and
problems has been one of
metabolism, physiology, and so forth.
They remain to be the carriers
of the ultimate signal,
but the brain ultimately appears
to be the conductor of this
orchestra of physiology and metabolism.
All right, now let's go to
the gut brain and sugar,
maybe.
- Please, please.
No, I mean,
the vagus nerve has in popular
culture has been kind of
converted into this single
meaning of calming pathways,
mostly because I actually
have to tip my hat
to the yogic community was
among the first to talk
about vagus on and on and on,
there are calming pathways,
so-called parasympathetic
pathways within the vagus.
But I think that the more
we learn about the vagus,
the more it seems like an entire
set of neural connections,
as opposed to one nerve.
I just wanted to just
mention that because I think
a lot of people have heard
about the vagus turns out experimentally
in the laboratory,
many neuroscientists
will stimulate the vagus
to create states of alertness
and arousal when animals,
or even people believe it
or not are close to dying
or going into coma stimulation
of the vagus is one of the ways
to wake up the brain counter to the idea
that it's just this I way
of calming oneself down.
- And also of course, I mean,
one has to be cautious they're in that.
So the vagus nerve is made
out of many thousands of fibers,
individual fibers that
make this gigantic bundle.
And it's likely as we're speaking,
that each of these fibers carries
a slightly different meaning,
not necessarily one by
one, maybe five is 10,
five is 20, do all right,
but they carry meaning that's associated
with their specific task.
This group of fibers is telling the brain
about the state of your heart.
This group of fiber is telling
the brain about the state of your gut.
This is telling your brain
about its nutritional state,
this, your pancreas, this your lungs.
And they are again, to make
the same simple example,
the keys of this piano.
Yes, you're right.
There is a lot of data,
showing that activating the
entire vagal bundle has very
meaningful effects in a
wide range of conditions.
In fact, it's being used to
treat untractable depression.
- A little stimulator.
- Epileptics seizures.
But again, there are thousands
of fibers carrying different functions.
So to some degree this is like
turning the lights on the stadium,
because you need to illuminate
where you lost your keys under your seat.
Yet 10,000 bulbs of a thousand
Watts each have just come on.
Only one of this is pointing to where,
and so I'm lucky enough that one
of them happened to point to my side.
So here you activate the
bundle thousands of fibers.
I'm lucky enough that some of
those happen to do something,
to make a meaningful
difference in depression,
or to make a meaningful
difference in epileptics.
But it should not be misconstrued
as arguing that this broad activation
has any type of
selectivity or specificity,
we're just lucky enough
that among all the things
that are being done, some
of those happen to change
the biology of these processes.
Now, the reason this is relevant
because the magic of this gut brain axis
is the fact that you have these thousands
of fibers really doing different
functions and our goal.
And along with many
other great scientists,
including Steve Lieder Lee,
that started a lot of
this molecular dissection
on this vagal gut brain
communication line at Harvard,
is trying to uncover what
each of those lines doing,
what are each of those
keys of this piano playing?
- What's the latest there?
Just as a brief update.
I know Steven Lieder Lee,
I think I was there when he got
his Howard Hughes and I did not.
So that was fun.
Always great to get beat
by excellent people.
- First of all, I'm happy you didn't,
because that way you can
focus on this amazing podcast.
- Well, thank you.
That's very gracious of you.
It's always feels better if not good
to get beat out by excellent people.
Steven is second to none.
And he is defining, as you said,
the molecular constituents
of different elements of
these many, many fibers,
is there an update there,
are they finding multiple
parallel pathways?
- They are, they are, some
that control heartbeat.
Some that control the respiratory cycle.
Some that might be involved
in a gastric movement.
You know, this notion that you're full
and you feel full in part
because your gut gets distended
your stomach, for example.
And then there are little
sensors that are reading
that and telling the brain you're full.
- So the textbooks will soon change
on the basis of the
Lieder Lee and other work.
- In essence, I think
we are learning enough
about these lines, that could
really help put together
this holistic view of how the brain
it's truly changing body physiology,
metabolism, and immunity,
the part that hasn't been yet developed,
and that it needs a fair amount of work,
but it's an exciting thrilling,
journey of discovery is how
the signal comes back to
now change that biology.
You know, the example I gave
you before with Pavlov's dog.
I figure out how the association created
this link between the bell,
but then how does the
brain tell the pancreas
to release in the right amount of insulin?
So,
let me tell you about the gut brain axis
and our insatiable
appetite for sugar and fat.
Insatiable for sugar,
unquenchable for fat.
And this is a story about
the fundamental difference
between liking and wanting.
Liking sugar is the function
of the taste system.
And it's not really liking sugar,
it's liking sweet,
wanting sugar,
our never ending appetite
for sugar is the story
of the gut brain axis,
liking versus wanting.
And this work is work
of my own laboratory.
You know, that began long ago
when we discovered the sweet receptors
and you can now engineer mice
that lack these receptors.
So in essence,
these animals will be unable
to taste sweet, a life without sweetness.
How horrible.
And if you give a normal mouse,
a bottle containing sweet,
and we're going to put either
sugar or an artificial sweetener,
they bottle sweet.
They have slightly different tastes,
but that's simply because
artificial sweeteners
have some off tastes.
But as far as the sweet
receptor is concerned,
they both activate the same receptor,
trigger the same signal.
And if you give an animal,
an option of a bottle containing sugar
or a sweetener versus water,
this animal will drink 10 to one
from the bottle containing sweet.
That's the taste system,
animal goes samples, each one,
licks a couple of licks and then says,
that's the one I want
because it's appetitive.
And because I love it.
- So it prefers sugar
to artificial sweetener?
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
In this experiment, this experiment,
I'm going to put only sweet in one bottle
and it could be either sugar
or artificial sweetener.
It doesn't matter which one.
We're going to do the next experiment
where we separate those two,
for now is sweet versus water.
And sweet means sweet, not sugar.
Sweet means anything that tastes sweet.
And sugar is one example and
Splenda is another example.
- Aspartame, monk fruit,
Stevia, doesn't matter.
- I mean, there's some
that only humans can taste.
Mice cannot taste because their receptors
between humans and mice are different,
but we have put the
human receptor into mice.
We engineer mice and we completely
humanize this mouse's taste world.
But for the purpose of this conversation,
we're only comparing sweet
versus water, an option.
My goodness,
they will lick to know and
from the sweet side 10 to one,
at least versus the water, makes sense?
All right, now we're
going to take the mice
and we're going to genetically engineer it
to remove the sweet receptors.
So this mice no longer
have in their oral cavity,
any sensors that can detect sweetness,
be that sugar molecule be
an artificial sweetener,
be anything else that tastes sweet.
And if you give this mice an option
between sweet versus water,
sugar versus water, artificial
sweetener versus water,
it will drink equally well from both
because he cannot tell them apart
because it doesn't have
the receptors for sweet.
So that sweet bottle
tastes just like water.
Makes sense?
- Makes sense.
- Very good.
Now we're going to do the experiment
with sugar from now on
let's focus on sugar.
So I'm going to give a mouse
out sugar versus water.
Normal mouse will drink from the sugar,
sugar, sugar, sugar, very
little from the water,
knock out the sweet
receptors, eliminate them.
Mouse can no longer tell them apart.
And they will drink from both.
But if I keep the mouse in that
case for the next 48 hours,
something extraordinary happens
when I come 48 hours later.
And I see what the mouse is
licking or drinking from,
that mouse is drinking almost exclusively
from the sugar bottle.
How could this be?
It cannot not taste it.
It doesn't have sweet
receptors during those 48 hours
the mouse learn that there is something
in that bottle that makes me feel good.
And that is the bottle I want to consume.
Now does the mouse identify that bottle?
It does so by using
other sensory features,
the smell of the bottle,
the texture of the solution inside, sugar,
the high concentrations is kind of goopy,
the side in which the
bottle is in the cage.
It doesn't matter what,
but the mouse realize there is something
there that makes me feel good.
And that's what I want.
And that is the fundamental
basis of our unquenchable
desire and our craving for sugar
and is mediated by the gut brain axis.
The first clue is that it
takes a long time to develop,
immediately suggesting
a post-ingestive effect.
So we reason if this is true
and it's the gut brain axis
that's driving sugar preference.
Then there should be a group
of neurons in the brain
that are responding to
post-ingestive sugar,
and low and behold,
we identify a group of
neurons in the brain
that does this and these neurons receive
their input directly from
the gut brain axis.
- From other neurons.
- You got it.
And so what's happening is that
sugar is recognized normally
by the tongue, activates
an appetitive response.
Now you ingest it and now it
activates a selective group
of cells in your intestines
that now send a signal to the brain
via the vagal ganglia that says,
I got what I need.
The tongue doesn't know
that you got what you need.
It only knows that you tasted it.
This knows that it got to the point
that it's going to be
used, which is the gut.
And now it sends the
signal to now reinforce
the consumption of this thing,
because this is the one that I needed.
Sugar, source of energy.
- And are these neurons in the gut?
- So these are not neurons in the gut.
So these are gut cells that
recognize the sugar molecule.
- [Andrew] I see.
- Send the signal and
that signal is received
by the vagal neuron directly.
- Got it.
- And it sends a signal
through the gut brain axis
to the cell bodies of these
neurons in the vagal ganglia,
and from there to the brain stem
to now trigger the preference for sugar.
- Two questions.
One, you mentioned that these cells
that detect sugar within
the gut are actually within the intestine.
You didn't say stomach.
Which surprised me.
I always think gut as
stomach, but of course-
- They're intestines,
because that's where all
the absorption happens.
- [Andrew] Got it.
- So you want the signal, you see,
you want the brain to know that
you had successful ingestion
and breakdown of whatever you consume into
the building blocks of life,
and glucose, amino acids, fat.
And so you want to make sure
that once they are in the form
that intestines can now absorb them,
is where you get the signal
back saying this what I want.
Now let me just take it one step further.
And this now sugar molecules
activates this unique gut brain
circuit that now drives the development
of our preference for sugar.
Now, a key element of this circuit
is that the sensors in
the gut that recognize
the sugar do not recognize
artificial sweeteners at all.
- Because their nutrient value
is uncoupled from the taste?
- Generically speaking one can make that,
but it's because it's a very
different type of receptor.
Turns out that it's not
the tongue receptors
being used in the gut.
It's a completely different
molecule that only recognizes
the glucose molecule, not
artificial sweeteners.
This has a profound impact
on the effect of ultimately
artificial sweeteners
in curbing our appetite, our craving,
our insatiable desire for sugar,
since they don't activate
the gut brain axis,
they'll never satisfy the craving
for sugar like sugar does.
And the reason I believe
that artificial sweeteners
have failed in the market
to curb our appetite.
Our need, our desire for sugar is
because they beautifully
work on the tongue.
They liking to recognize
sweet versus non-sweet,
but they fail to activate the key sensors
in the gut that now inform the brain
you got sugar, no need to crave anymore.
- So the issue of wanting,
can we relate that to a particular
set of neurochemicals upstream,
so the pathway is, so glucose
is activating the cells
in the gut that through the vagus
that's communicated through the presumably
the nodus ganglia and
up into the brain stem.
- Very good, and from
there, where does it go?
- Yeah, where does it go,
and what is the substrate of wanting?
Of course I think molecules
like dopamine craving,
there's a book even called the
molecule of more, et cetera.
Dopamine is a very diabolical
molecule, as you know,
because it evokes both
a sense of pleasure-ish,
but also a sense of
desiring more, of craving.
So if I understand you correctly,
artificial sweeteners are,
and I agree are failing as a means
to satisfy sugar craving at
the level of nutrient sensing.
And yet if we trigger this
true sugar evoked
wanting pathway too much,
and we've all experienced this,
then we eat sugar and we find ourselves
wanting more and more sugar.
Now that could also be
insulin dysregulation,
but can we uncouple those?
- I mean, look,
if we have a mega problem
with over consumption of sugar and fat,
we're facing a unique time
in our evolution where
diseases of malnutrition
are due to over-nutrition.
I mean, how nuts is that?
Historically, diseases of malnutrition
have always been linked to undernutrition.
And so we need to come up with strategies
that can meaningfully change
the activation of these
circuits that control
our wanting certainly in
the populations at risk,
and this gut brain circuit that ultimately
it's the lines of communication
that are informing
the brain, the presence
of intestinal sugar,
in this example,
it's a very important target
in the way we think about,
is there a way that we can
meaningfully modulate these circuits?
So I make your brain think
that you got satisfied with sugar,
even though I'm not giving you sugar.
- So that immediately raises
the question are the receptors
for glucose in these gut cells susceptible
to other things that are healthier for us.
- That's very good.
Excellent idea.
And I think an important
goal will be to come up
with a strategy and identify
those very means that allow us to
modulate the circuits in a way
that certainly for all of those,
where this is a big issue,
it can really have a,
you know, dramatic impact
in improving human health.
- I could be wrong about this.
And I'm happy to be wrong.
I'm often wrong.
And told I'm wrong, that we
have cells within our gut
that don't just sense sugar,
glucose to be specific,
but also cells within our gut
that sense amino acids and fatty acids.
I could imagine a scenario
where one could train themselves
to feel immense amounts of
satiety from the consumption
of foods that are rich in essential
fatty acids, amino acids,
perhaps less caloric
or less insulin dysregulating than sugar.
I'll use myself as an example.
I've always enjoyed sweets,
but in the last few years,
for some reason I've
started to lose my appetite
for them probably because I
just don't eat them anymore.
At first that took some restriction.
Now I just don't even think about it.
- And you're not reinforcing the circuits.
And so you're in essence
are removing yourself from,
but you tend to be the exception.
You know, we have a huge,
a incredible large number
of people that are being
continuously exposed to
highly processed foods.
- And hidden, so called hidden sugars.
- They don't even have to be hidden.
You know, it's right there.
- Hiding in plain sight.
I agree so much is made of
hidden sugars that we often
overlook that there are
also the overt sugars.
- I mean, we can have a long discussion
on the importance of
coming up with strategies
that could meaningfully
change public health
when it comes to nutrition.
But I want to just go
back to the notion of
this brain centers that
are ultimately the ones
that are being activated by
these essential nutrients.
So sugar, fat, amino acids are
building blocks of our diets.
And this is across all animal species.
So it's not unreasonable
then to assume that
dedicated brain circuits
would've evolved to
ensure their recognition,
their ingestion and the reinforcement
that that is what I need.
And indeed animals
evolve these two systems.
One is the taste system that allows you
to recognize them and trigger
this predetermined, hardwired,
immediate responses.
Oh my goodness.
This tastes so good.
It's so sweet.
I personally have a sweet tooth,
and you know, oh my God,
this is so delicious.
It's fatty or umami,
recognizing the amino acids.
So that's the liking pathway,
but in the wisdom of evolution,
that's good,
but doesn't quite do it.
You want to make sure that
these things get to the place
where they're needed and they're
not needed in your tongue.
They're needed in your intestines
where they're going to be absorbed
as the nutrients that will support life.
And the brain wants to know this,
and it wants to know it
in a way that it can now
form the association between
that I just tasted is what got
where it needs to be.
And it makes me feel good.
And so now next time
that I have to choose,
what should I eat?
That association now guides me to,
that's the one I want.
I want that fruit, not that fruit.
I want those leaves,
not those leaves, because these
are the ones that activate
the right circuits that ensure that
the right nutrients got to the right place
and told the brain, this
is what I want and need.
Are we on?
- We're on.
One thing that intrigues
me and puzzles me,
is that this effect took a
couple of days, at least in mice.
And the sensation, ah, sorry,
the perception of taste is immediate.
and yet this is a slow system.
And so in a beautiful way, but
in a kind of mysterious way,
the brain is able to couple
the taste of a sweet drink
with the experience of
nutrient extraction in the gut,
under a context where
the mouse and the human
is presumably ingesting other
things, smelling other mice,
smelling other people.
That's incredible.
- But you have to think
of it not as humans,
remember we inherited the
circuits of our ancestors
and they through evolutionary
from their ancestors.
And we haven't had that many
years to have fundamentally
changed in many
of these hardwired circuits.
So forget as humans,
let's look at animals in the wild.
Which is easier now to
comprehend the logic.
You know, why should this take
a long time of continued reinforcement
given that I can taste it in a second?
You want to make sure that this
source of sugar, for example,
in the wild is the best.
Is the richest.
It's the one where I get the most energy
for the least amount of extraction,
the least amount of work.
I want to identify rich sources of sugar.
And if the system simply
responds immediately
to the first sugar that gets to your gut,
you're going to form the association
with those sources of food,
which are not the ones that
you should be eating from.
- Don't fall in love with the
first person you encounter.
- Oh my goodness, exactly.
And so evolutionarily by
having the taste system,
giving you the immediate recognition,
but then by forcing this gut brain axis
to reinforce it only when sustained
repeated exposure has informed the brain.
This is the one you don't want
to form the association before.
And so when we remove it from the context
of we just go to the supermarket,
we're not hunting there in
the wild where I need to form.
And so what's is that
highly processed foods are
hijacking, co-opting
these circuits in a way
that it would've never happened in nature.
And then we not only find
these things appetitive
and palatable, but in addition,
we are continuously reinforcing,
the wanting in a way that,
oh my God, this is so great.
What do I feel like eating?
Let me have more of this.
- You've just forever changed the way
that I think about
supermarkets and restaurants.
There are understanding
this fast signaling
and this slower signaling
and the utility of having
both makes me realize
that supermarkets and restaurants are
about the most unnatural
thing for our system ever,
almost the equivalent of living
in small villages with
very few suitable mates
versus online dating, for instance.
- I'm not going to make
a judgment call there
because they do serve
an important purpose.
- I like restaurants too.
- And so do supermarkets, thank God.
I think they're not the culprits.
I think the culprits of course
are our reliance
on foods that are not necessarily healthy.
Now, going back to the supermarket,
don't fall in love with the
first, they need to work.
You know, you take
a tangerine,
and you take an extract of tangerine
that you used to cook that
spiked, let's say with sugar
and you equalize in both
where they both provide the
same amount of calories.
If you eat them both,
they're going to have
a very different effect
in your gut brain axis on your system.
Once you make the extract and
you process it and you add
processed sugar to use
it now to cook, to add,
to make it really sweet tangerine thing.
Now you're providing now fully ready
to use broken down source of sugar,
in the tangerine that sugar's
mixed in the complexity
of a whole set of other
chemical components,
fiber, long chains of sugar molecules
that need a huge amount
of work by your stomach,
your gut system, to break it down.
So you are using a huge amount of energy
to extract energy and the balance
it's very different that when
I take this process highly
extracted tangerine,
by the way I use tangerines
because I had a tangerine
just before I came here.
- Delicious, they are delicious.
- And so this goes back to
the issue of supermarkets.
And to some degree, given a choice,
you don't want to eat
highly processed foods
because everything's already
been broken down for you.
And so your system has no work.
And so you are,
co-opting hijacking the circuits in a way
that they're being activated
at a time scale that
normally wouldn't happen.
- Well, this is why I often feel that,
and I think a lot of data
are now starting to support
the idea that while indeed the
laws of thermodynamics apply
calories ingested versus calories burned
is a very real thing, right?
That the appetite for certain foods
and the wanting and the liking
are phenomena of the nervous system,
brain and gut as you've
beautifully described.
And that changes over time,
depending on how we are
receiving these nutrients.
- Absolutely.
Look,
we have a lot of work to do.
I'm talking as society.
I'm not talking about you and I.
- We also have a lot of work to do.
- Now.
I think understanding
the circuits is giving us important
insights in how ultimately,
and hopefully we can improve human health
and make a meaningful difference.
Now, it's very easy to try to connect
the dots A to B, B to C, C to D.
And I think there's a lot
more complexity to it,
but I do think that the
lessons that are emerging
out of understanding how
these circuits operate,
can ultimately inform how
we deal with our diets
in a way that we avoid
what we're facing now as a society.
I mean it's nuts that
over-nutrition happens
to be such a prevalent problem.
And I also think the training
of people who are thinking
about metabolic science and
metabolic disease is largely
divorced from the training
of the neuroscientist and vice versa.
No one field is to blame,
but I fully agree that
the brain is the key over,
or the nervous system
to be more accurate is one of
the key overlooked features.
- Is the arbiter,
ultimately is the arbiter
of many of these pathways.
- As a final question.
And one which is simply
to entertain my curiosity
and the curiosity of the listeners.
What is your absolute favorite food?
- Oh, my goodness.
- Taste, I should say.
Taste to distinguish between taste
and the nutritive value or lack thereof.
- Look, we, unlike every animal
and every animal species
eat for the enjoyment of it,
it doesn't happen in the wild,
most animals eat when they need to eat.
Doesn't mean they don't enjoy it,
but it's a completely different story.
I have too many favorite foods
because I enjoy the sensory
experience rather than the food itself
to me is the whole thing, is
from the presentation, look,
there've been these experiments
done in psycho physics,
I'm going to take a salad,
made out of 11 components
and I'm going to mix
them all up in potpourri
greens and other things here.
And in the other one,
I'm going to present it in
a beautiful arrangement.
And I'm going to put them behind
a glass cabinet and
I'm going to sell them.
And I'm going to sell one
for $2 and one for $8,
precisely the same ingredient.
Exactly the same amount of each.
Ultimately you're going to mix them,
they're all going to be the same,
and people will pay the
$8 because you know what,
it evokes a different person.
It gives you the feel
that, oh my goodness,
I'm going to enjoy that salad.
So going back to,
what is my favorite food,
to me eating is really
a sensory journey.
I don't mean the every
day, let me have some
chicken wings, because
I'm hungry it, but eh,
every piece I think has an important
evoking sensory role.
And so in terms of categories
of food I grew up in Chile.
So meat has always been,
but I eat it so seldom now.
- Is that right?
- Yeah, because I know that it's
not necessarily the healthiest thing,
red meat I'm talking about.
And so I grew up eating it every day.
I'm talking seven days a
week, Chile, Argentina,
that's the mainstay of our diet.
Now maybe I have red meat.
I don't know, once every four weeks.
- And you enjoy it?
- Oh, I love it.
Part of it is because I
haven't had it in four weeks.
But you know, I love sushi,
but I love the art of
sushi, the whole thing,
the way it's presented, it
changes the way you taste it.
I love ethnic food in particular.
- You're in the right place.
- You got it, that was the main reason
I wanted to come to New York.
No, I'm just kidding.
- There's also that
Columbia University that's-
- And I came here because
I wanted to be with
people that are thinking about the brain,
the same way that I like to think,
which can we solve this big
problem, this big question.
- And certainly you're
making amazing strides
in that direction.
And I love your answer because
it really brings together
the many features of the circuitries
and the phenomena we've
been talking about today,
which is that while it begins
with sensation and perception,
ultimately it's the context.
And that context is highly
individual to person,
place and time, and
many, many other things
on behalf of myself.
And certainly on behalf
of all the listeners,
I want to thank you, first of all,
for the incredible work
that you've been doing now for decades,
in vision, in taste and
in this bigger issue
of how we perceive and experience life,
it's truly pioneering and incredible work.
And I feel quite lucky to
have been on the sidelines,
seeing this over the years
and hearing the talks
and reading the countless
beautiful papers,
but also for your time today
to come down here and talk to us
about what drives you and
the discoveries you've made.
Thank you ever so much.
- It was great fun.
Thank you for having me.
- We'll do it again.
- We shall.
- Thank you for joining me today
for my discussion about
perception and in particular,
the perception of taste
with Dr. Charles Zuker.
If you're learning from, and
or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please subscribe
to the podcast on Spotify and Apple
and on Spotify and Apple,
you can leave us up to a five star review.
If you have feedback for us in terms
of comments related to
topics we've covered,
or questions or topics or
guests that you'd like us
to cover on future episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do read all the comments.
On today's episode of
the Huberman Lab Podcast,
we didn't talk about supplements,
but on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
we talk about supplements
that are useful for sleep,
for focus, for hormone support
and other aspects of mental health,
physical health, and performance.
If you're interested in
some of those supplements,
you can go to
livemomentous.com/huberman to see
the catalog of supplements that
we've helped them formulate.
And that map directly onto
specific protocols described
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
we are Huberman Lab on Twitter
and Huberman Lab on Instagram.
And at both Twitter and Instagram,
I cover science and science related tools.
Some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is distinct
from the information contained
in the Huberman Lab Podcast.
We also have a newsletter in
which we spell out protocols
and some summaries from
previous podcast episodes.
If you'd like to check those out,
you can go to hubermanlab.com,
go to the menu and you'll find
the Neural Network Newsletter.
You can sign up for that newsletter simply
by providing an email,
it's completely zero cost.
We have a very strict privacy policy.
We do not share your email with anybody.
Again, that's hubermanlab.com,
go to the menu and look for
the Neural Network Newsletter.
And if you'd like examples
of previous newsletters,
you'll also find those at hubermanlab.com.
Once again, thank you
for joining me today,
my discussion with Dr. Charles Zuker
about the biology of
perception and the biology
of the perception of taste in particular,
I hope you found that discussion
to be as enriching as I did.
And last, but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[light rock music]